so cars are something that usually
involves some type of insurance One cars
are a pretty expensive asset that many
of us own the other issue is cars are
driving around pretty fast and they can
actually cause a lot of damage to
property or two people
and so for the first thing to think
about of any type of insurance is what's
the premium what do you pay for that
insurance and then
um what's the deductible remember in
other videos we talk about that
deductible if you have a five thousand
dollar deductible that means you have to
spend the first five thousand dollars
yourself people will often say that's
out of pocket and then the insurance
kicks in usually the higher the
deductible for a given amount of
coverage or depending on the different
dimensions of coverage the lower the
premium is going to be because the
insurance company feels like well yeah
it's going to be less likely that we're
going to have to pay for something but
then above and beyond premiums and
deductibles there's a lot of different
dimensions of automobile insurance the
First Dimension is that of liability and
liability really matters because a car
might cost tens of thousands of dollars
but if heaven forbid you were to run
into someone or cause damage to someone
else especially if it's if they could
get really hurt or worse you could be
liable for hundreds of thousands of
dollars so it could be much more
expensive than the car itself and many
states actually require you to actually
have liability insurance even if you
aren't required I highly recommend that
you have liability insurance no matter
how carefully you drive and I do
recommend you drive carefully accidents
do happen people clearly get hurt on the
road and if someone were to sue you and
you were to lose a lawsuit that would
cost a lot of money and even if you
don't lose the lawsuit the legal
expenses can be a lot so having
liability insurance can help out there
now Beyond liability obviously uh what
most people think of when they think of
car insurance is your car gets into an
accident there is some damage involved
how do you repair that damage so that is
collision insurance and many car
insurances they'll say okay we're going
to cover liability for this much we're
going to cover Collision for this much
and that's pure if you get an accident
you are covered for that now sometimes
there's another little piece called
uninsured insurance or if someone is
underinsured or uninsured and your car
gets damaged well then and and really
they were at fault some states don't try
to say who is at fault and different
people's Insurance just cover their own
stuff but in other states they say okay
who is at fault if let's say I get into
a car accident with you and if I was at
fault if I'm if they if they decide that
I was at fault then my insurance would
have to cover not just the damage to my
car but to your car as well but then if
I wasn't insured then you would have a
situation where you have the
underinsured or uninsured policy where
if you get into an accident with someone
who's not insured even if they were in
fault that it will still cover it so you
have the liability you have the
Collision if you actually get into an
accident and there's damage we could
talk about if it covers the uh you know
the uninsured or underinsured side of
things but then what if a situation
where you didn't get into a car accident
a tree falls on your car or hail damages
your car or someone steals your car well
that's comprehensive coverage so
Collision is an accident comprehensive
covers all of these other things it is
literally comprehensive and then the
last Dimension is medical expenses
obviously none of us want to fall into
one of these situations but if you get
into a car accident it's not it's not
just your car that might get damaged you
or other occupants in your car or
someone else's car might get hurt as
well and as you know medical expenses or
maybe you don't know medical expenses
could easily be tens of thousands of
dollars it could be more costly than
than the value of the car itself so once
again that's another piece of insurance
so when you get into a policy look at
what you're paying look at the premium
but not all ensure and look at the
deductible but not all insurances are
equivalent obviously you have different
deductibles but they all have a
different amounts some you should see
whether your policy even covers you know
liability versus Collision versus
comprehensive versus medical expenses
what are the different deductibles do
they have limits under those do they
have certain restrictions where it might
not apply does it apply if only you're
the driver or someone else is the driver
so these are all the details that it's
really good for you to know about when
you're making uh Insurance purchasing
decisions